luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the show of course it is empowered by icon plus
capital the vc company so matthew welcome to the
show how are you pleased to be here today leah
thank you for having me yeah it's such a pleasure
i'm really excited to jump in i have a million and
one questions but before we do um i just want
to let everybody know that this is sponsored by
blockbuy and you can actually get up to 250 when
you sign up um i think you can get around six
percent interest which is really cool so there's a
link somewhere for you so matthew you are the ceo
of sino global capital for those i don't know
to give us a brief picture as to what you guys
do sure so we invest we as strategic investors in
the best blockchain projects all around the world
and the reason it's a strategic check is we help
our portfolio companies here in mainland china
which certainly as we've seen in the last week
or so is arguably the most important market
in crypto and certainly among the major markets
is the most esoteric and really impenetrable for
international projects so basically we touch four
bases east west finance and technology and we're
pretty good across those four bases and we invest
uh in crypto but as more with a traditional vc
approach namely that we find people that we think
are [ __ ] awesome that we want to hang out with
for the long term and we support them uh here
in china so we look for the best people around
the world people like uh like ftt and serum and
solana people like sam bankman freed and anatoly
from solana and we support them day in day
out here with boots on the ground in china
i think um with everything that's going on um
with china and over the last two weeks it's
such a fascinating place to be based because it's
really hard to understand exactly what is going on
and just how much the market is being
affected so i i want to go through all of it
um i really don't fully have um a hold
on the situation so given you're there
just to start with the absolute basics
what are the attitudes like towards crypto
so i i think it's it's difficult to answer
questions like that because really you have
so many different constituencies so when you
say added towards attitudes towards crypto you
have a small number of people that are engaging
with crypto in a sophisticated institutional way
you have a vast swath of people that are engaging
in a retail way you have uh regulators uh you have
all kinds of different uh people with all kinds
of different views so i think it's kind of tough
to to answer in that way um the the best way
really to answer it is that i mean how would
you answer that for the us you have some people
think it's [ __ ] you have some people think it's
the greatest thing ever and they're tweeting about
doge or whatever you have some people that are hot
and cold like elon you got all kinds of people so
it's really similar in in that respect i would say
but if i if i looked at india for example or
nigeria i could sort of say a clean you know
okay well their governments are hostile towards
it and that's really obvious but china it's really
hard to understand what's going on there's a lot
of flip-flopping um you know every go on yagon
oh i'm sorry so if you narrow the question to the
chinese government then that's easier to answer
so i would answer thusly so the chinese government
uh views blockchain as a strategic technology much
in the way that they do technology such as ai
and 5g they view it as enormously important and
that's why for example they've been working
on their shoes that will be their digital
currency for years now and it's finally uh on
the on about to come to fruition um so that's
blockchain though and as we know blockchain is
for sure not the same thing as crypto uh that's
more distributed ledger type thing it's not pure
crypto right so um conversely i think that they're
kind of wary and not super comfortable with
crypto because it engages and overlaps with
strategic technology blockchain in many ways they
don't quite want to just shut it down entirely
but they're they're kind of wary of it and i think
that wariness explains hot and cold behavior in in
some ways but stepping back from that i think
that um one reason that it's quite difficult to
interpret there are several reasons but
one reason quite difficult to interpret
chinese government pronouncements is that
you need a lot of contextual knowledge
and so part of that contextual knowledge that
i think is super important in understanding the
chinese government action with respect to crypto
is you need to know where the the third rails are
the third rail is that that electric rail that
you can't touch so the chinese government with
respect to crypto the first third rail is that
uh they're enormously sensitive to anything
that interacts with the currency control regime uh
as most people probably know the renminbi is not
a free floating currency like the united states
dollar it's a strictly controlled currency and so
anything that could potentially be
an end around or weaken the currency
control regime that's a that's a third
rail they're enormously sensitive to that
so that's the first one uh the second one then is
anything uh so the first two are related the the
the second one then is uh fiat on and off ramp
and anything related to aml and tax evasion um
uh and then the third thing i would say is uh
anything related to excessive retail speculation
and so it's important to understand
that um there are a lot of
even before crypto and even now but
not related to crypto there's a lot of
uh mlm and ponzi type financial schemes
uh here in china called tsujinpan
and um so these things uh can really metastasize
metastasize overnight especially on a regional
basis and so um what you can have is you
can have tens of thousands of people in some
kind of random city that have all invested in a
[ __ ] coin if you're lucky maybe there's some
actual value there but probably there's not so
probably they're investing in some ponzi coin
and it may be very regional and then when it
collapses you can suddenly have thousands or
even tens of thousands of very pissed off people
in a specific place that are almost kind of like
mobilizing and and you know potentially even
protesting and so the government is enormously
sensitive to this kind of potential retail and
investor unrest so i think when you interpret
chinese government pronouncements one reason
it's it's so difficult is you you have to
understand what is actually super important to
them and then kind of start on that basis i think
so you just to go back a second you mentioned
fiat on and off ramps is it difficult
for a retail investor to actually buy bitcoin
out there so it that i i would say it like this
um there is enormous creativity in um in finding
ways to to get done what you want to get done
so people have uh by observation there's an
almost endlessly creative uh solution space
that people have in in order to get in and out but
um it's it's something that's enormously sensitive
frankly this is a topic that that we know a lot
less about because we don't go anywhere near there
i've literally never gone from fiat in or out to
crypto ever not even once uh wait i just wanna i
just why not because this is something that's very
sensitive and so i i like to sleep very peacefully
so cyno has literally never done that
ever we never touched remy ever not
even ever so uh it's an area that the point
though being that it's an area that we know
a little bit less about because of that um but you
know by observation there is enormous energy that
goes into finding end arounds for this kind of
thing but it's it's a very uh at best it's a
gray area and it's a very uh dangerous activity
as we saw uh i guess it was about a year ago
with a famous china ogee who who was arrested for
this type of activity it's actually a bitfinex
uh shareholder um and and these things
definitely happen from time to time it's not
something you you want to be involved
with but but people spend a lot of energy
on this and they for sure do find ways to do it
for sure but this is it's no change that that's
a sensitive activity that's something that has
been the case for quite a long period of time
okay so would you then say operating in china
um in this industry is difficult because if we
compare it to the uk where i'm based right now
it's super easy it's so easy to buy bitcoin it's
it everything is so you know there's no
threat or any concern or anything like that
i think it kind of depends
what you're looking to do
so certainly um if you already have money in
crypto you are free to currently free to uh
trade crypto uh if you already have money in
in the crypto system so to speak as long as
you're compliant with aml and and uh and tax
and such um and and and so you know ultimately
it depends what what you're looking to do it it's
definitely a more much more complicated landscape
uh even for uh you know native chinese or people
that are fully expert in the chinese market
um and and that's for sure for many reasons
one reason is that um in the west we have uh
pretty much a black and white legal landscape
which is why another reason why it's difficult for
people understand what's going on in china uh in
the uk or in the united states it's kind of like
you have you know 30 percent of things that
are definitely illegal and then you have 68
percent of things that are definitely illegal and
then you have a gray area that's kind of like 2
in china it's more like you have 15
of things that are definitely illegal
and 40 of things that are definitely
legal and then you have a huge gray area
so that's a very different framework to
operate in to have an enormous gray area
rather than you know a very a very black and
white landscape uh that's another reason it's
super difficult for people to understand um
what's going on in china because you have kind
of what's on paper in in the west i think that
the overlap between what's on paper and what's
actually taking place on the ground is you know
enormous it's a huge overlap in china there's a
substantially uh the the overlap is
substantially less you definitely
can't understand the landscape by just looking
at what's on paper that will definitely get you
very confused very quickly uh so you you
have to have an understanding of two things
number one what's on paper number two facts on
the ground and then the third thing you also
need to understand how those two interact and how
that might change over time so it's definitely uh
in a way more nuanced yeah and i think i think
the confusion comes in because every single
bull market and you know we've seen over the
last few weeks there's always news coming out
um of china that you know they've
banned this or they've stopped that so
and then also actually i think it was about three
weeks ago i made a video because china actually
made gave the green light on something bitcoin
related so then that's a bit of a flip-flop there
so how can the same news keep coming out i think
that's kind of what i don't understand are they
they just re um reinforce a previous
um hostility from 2017 for example
so i would phrase it like this um one
way the chinese government manages um
financial markets and including
crypto is that they use signaling
as a way to tamp down on excessive speculative
forces for example so some uh so so as the the
market goes through a bowl and bearing cycles
in a bull cycle we can expect that the chinese
government at some point is likely to signal
that things are getting a little too um
a little too frothy so in that sense that
that's something that would be a repeated action
against across rather many years uh so that's
the first thing but just on that point nothing
is actually changing it's merely a signal well i
i think that that is um i i think that that's too
simple of you in 2017 it's definitely true that
there was a crackdown on ico related activities
uh it's also definitely true that there were
counter responses uh even to the point of
of small things such as uh people know that they
can't talk freely probably about icos on wechat
so they start using little codes like ic0 or
whatever was one that was very common so um it's
important to understand that first that people
are enormously creative at moving around with the
the central government based in beijing may want
at any given time and that can uh reveal itself
in several aspects that can reveal itself in the
fact that sometimes there's a disconnect between
uh the central government and regional or local
governments number one and number two that there's
again these creative solutions uh to to uh moving
around government uh policy imperatives and i'm
trying to remember the expression off the top of
my head but it's something like the the mountains
are high and the emperor is far far away something
like that but uh you know the point is that what
the central government base in beijing wants to
get done is not always what will ultimately happen
uh there's also the expression uh shangyou shayo
duisu which basically means that there are there
are uh you know measures and then there are
counter measures so in beijing they might
want one thing and then locally they they might
find a way to get done what they want to get done
understood there's a lot of complicated nuances
yeah no i i get that and i really appreciate you
breaking that down um it is so difficult to fully
understand what is going on um because like you
said what happens in practice isn't necessarily
um doesn't necessarily reflect what's what's
happening on paper um but this week there was um
apparently in the news that said um a crackdown
um on bitcoin miners in beijing so before we get
into that how correct is that so i i think that's
uh i i would not phrase it that way i would
phrase it as this so um there was a routine
policy meeting related to financial stability not
specifically bitcoin not specifically crypto but
overall financial stability uh a routine meeting
and as part of that meeting there was a line item
which was uh related specifically to crypto
including bitcoin mining so i i think first of all
it's uh important to understand that this is not a
story specifically about crypto it's a story about
how the chinese government doesn't like
excessive financial speculation especially retail
now it is true that that was a meeting at the
vice premier level and the vice premier is uh
is the point person for economic policy so it is
true that it's very serious in in that regard but
i would view it as this is an initial indication
that the government is very closely studying these
issues and is uh evaluating possible
uh policies that could be implemented
uh that's quite different than um overnight
bitcoin mining is banned something like that yeah
um so there are a lot of open questions
such as is is this something that
would be implemented at the national level is
this something that would be implemented at the
provincial level what would be the possible scope
for example are we talking about bitcoin mining or
are we talking about unauthorized bitcoin mining
because that's two extremely different things
so there are a lot of open questions and i
i think as a result it's very important to
use one's contextual knowledge of china and
evaluate a range of possibilities and try to
put a probability on those uh the fact is that uh
when the chinese government moves it frequently
starts as high-level opaque policy pronouncements
which are very difficult to interpret that's kind
of where we are now and then as time goes on
you can start with details around those so
that so therefore i think uh a credible
analysis would say that there's a wide
range of potential outcomes and we're trying
to put probabilities on those um it it's
much less or maybe even not credible if
we start to see things saying uh bitcoin
mining banned bitcoin in china is over you know
something like that doesn't make any sense to me
um so i would kind of suggest that that's a good
way to look at it yeah it makes a lot of sense and
i feel like i definitely have a better grip now
on the situation of understanding how it works
um there are always these concerns that
bitcoin mining is centralized in china
before we get into what that could mean um i
just wanted to know where you stand on that
well so i i think uh if is the question uh am
i concerned that uh the region the country of
china which is also a region am i concerned
that there's so much uh mining hash rate
in china not are you concerned not are you
concerned but do you think that there is
like a lot of people say that it's centralized
um and then they say they're not that actually
for whatever reason that's not actually
a problem and like you said you know
that's a true statement that there's a lot of hash
rate in china that's definitely a true statement
in uh especially in um in sichuan and xinjiang
those two provinces there's uh enormous
uh hash rate i mean that's a factual statement am
i worried about that not really i think uh people
make the assumption that these are actors that are
all kind of on the same page and could act like a
cartel and that that's a risk factor in some way
and i uh i'm skeptical that it could ever work
that way in practice you have a lot of disparate
actors with varied incentives i think that it
would be quite difficult to get them all on the
same page to act not only together but in a way
that is potentially against their own economic
incentives i'm i'm quite skeptical of these
narratives but yeah sure it's a factual statement
that there's huge hash rate in china that's true
well so you mentioned sichuan so sichuan is one
of the areas where um there's a lot of renewable
energy so people are mining there just because
you know when there's a high supply obviously the
prices for mining is lower so i want to talk
about energy everything that's been going on
at the moment um of course you know elon musk
did that whole flip-flop um one minute tesla
are accepting bitcoin the next minute they're not
accepting bitcoin um so just not my favorite thing
yeah go on why what happened there for
you yeah you know i i think look it's
crypto is a unique space right i mean i myself
should post on twitter yeah probably somewhat
famously i like to [ __ ] pose but i i also try
to be responsible about the way i do it and so um
and and and i i think there's
a way to do things in a fun way
yeah and there's a way to do things
in an irresponsible way and so uh even
you know a a crypto person like myself
is is concerned about that and to have
elon [ __ ] musk who's what second richest
person in the world as of today to be
fundamentally in my view irresponsible i think
it's incredibly disappointing i think that um
um he's larping much of the time i mean i do think
he's interested in crypto he thinks it's fun and
he's probably interested in it for legitimate
reasons as well but um look he he can't make jokes
about tess buying tesla at 420 anymore so he's
finding a different way to larp and i think it
sucks honestly i think it's [ __ ] i think it's um
it would be irresponsible even for someone like me
and for the second richest person in the world to
be acting like that i think it's [ __ ] basically
yeah i can really understand the frustration of
people in the community especially when you know
people try so hard for example like nick carter
to try and really explain um how bitcoin can
use renewable energy and how it's actually in that
positive i think it's satoshi him or her or myself
i think sorry interrupt i think we got to be
a little careful because um i i think that
it's very um i mean we have our own vested
interests right so uh many of us have most
of our net worth in crypto and
we're working in crypto full-time
but i think you have to be intellectually
honest also and i don't claim to be a mining
expert there are many other people who are
uh more understanding of mining than i am
that's not a primary focus at
sino however uh i i think that um
we we should be my suggest i would let me phrase
it this way my suggestion is that we need to be
intellectually honest and not act like we're a
bitcoin lobbying firm trying to push a narrative
so i think we need to be super careful about
uh engaging with the bitcoin as something
environmentally friendly narrative in a way that
speaks to the facts and is intellectually honest
uh now i again i am not a foremost mining
expert by any stretch uh i'm a a a china
focused person but not with a specific mining uh
competency but my my observation for sure is that
uh some of these narratives feel more like bitcoin
big bitcoin lobbying uh then something that is
intellectually honest that's my opinion yeah no
i i totally understand because i think you know
saying that bitcoin is green energy or use you
know bitcoin is green is definitely a stretch you
know like everything uses energy i think the point
that people have to stress is that well why don't
we compare it to what we currently have now and
sort of go from there and understand whether it's
better whether it's worth it whether it is greener
not green but greener i think maybe that's like a
sure a key point um i i fully support that i fully
support nuanced discussions about different kinds
of trade-offs i think that's something that's
super important um or what i don't like is
pushing it a story is where i i think
it's helpful for even as someone who is
full-time crypto and has a lot of at stake
along with the rest of us right i don't think
it's the right thing i don't think it's helpful
for anyone to push a story and not engage with um
with things in an intellectually honest way that
that's my suggestion and i think nuance is just
impossible over twitter um you know if that's
anything that i've learned it is twitter is not
made twitter is not made for debate i will i can
debate that for ages yeah i mean look obviously
i think we all know that i love twitter probably
way too much but um i i definitely agree with that
it's very very difficult to have
nuance on twitter look obviously right
but you can also have things that are clearly
like a [ __ ] way of going about your business
where it's just you're just talking nonsense and
you're you're just um um you know lobbying or
you know fun but but and so i don't really mind [
__ ] posting but then when when people are pushing
uh simplistic you know almost even intellectually
dishonest narratives that's different shitposting
i think of this just like maybe that's not what
people mean when they say that but to me i think
of it as like uh fun talking trash type type thing
to me that's okay but what's not okay is trying to
uh twist twist the reality of our industry
yeah i understand and i think i think talking
about intellectual honesty so important
um and that nuance is really important
um but off the back of all of this the
mighty bitcoin council came about so that
was all very exciting um this caused a lot of
backlash um and it it was really polarizing
so before i give my views what are your views on
a bitcoin council put together by two billionaires
i'm not super i don't have strong feelings on this
one i'm not okay opposed to it um i i mean i i
think in general i'm someone that gets very worked
up about monopoly power and things like that um
at the same time uh i'm not opposed to
different stakeholders working together
uh if they are truly trying to uh you know
make improvements and and be pro-social i i
i don't necessarily have strong feelings on it
at this time i i think it comes down to intent
and i think that's an open question but but i
think then again you know i'm not like i i'm
more of a candidly i'm more of a post-etherium
d5 kind of guy i'm not really like the old-school
austrian economics libertarian type if i were i
would probably be furious about bitcoin mining
council but that's not really me understood i
think it's the idea of having this trustless
network where there's no centralized power and
we all have one incentive which is basically
make money pay back those mining um fees those
those energy costs so i i can fully understand the
frustration i mean for me personally i am there's
i want to say a die hard libertarian but i really
my heart really feels the the pull towards
um not having centralized power but that's
interesting though so did you we were you that
libertarian and then you moved and sort of
moved more towards when i was when i was like 19
okay usually it's the other way around usually
usually when you're younger sorry go on i went
through i'm randy and phase i did i read all
i read every single one of iran's
books when i was like 17 18 19.
i i definitely went through that phase at one
point but usually it's when you're younger
so when i was about six years ago you get more
conservative when you get older but i'm not sure
conservative is the same thing as libertarian and
i certainly would argue that you're not but it's
not uh i do think that to some extent libertarian
is i mean a lot of people go through a libertarian
phase in their late teens and early twenties
don't don't they when they other way around yet
no no way i totally disagree with you i think
socialism when you're young socialists in your 20s
you know when nobody's working and
they're not paying their own bills
they're happy for socialism when you start making
your own money and you're paying your own bills
and you're working hard to pay those bills you
then lean a bit more to libertarianism i would say
could be could be you're you're in the
uk though right you guys are still pretty
normal well you got brexit but but the
united states has taken a weird lurch
over my lifetime so my my politics have stayed
basically the same but i went from like uh
probably like uh i i went from maybe a republican
voter to uh to you know to abide in type guy
even though my politics have basically stayed the
same but i i can see from your facial expression
we're probably not going to find a lot of common
ground here no i i don't like biden if i could
if i could fit in really nicely in in america
it would be somewhere in texas or florida
that just that's me christ are you are you sure
oh i'm totally sure i'm totally sure i can i can
or texas would you go would you go to miami
or would you go like completely nuts and go
like the florida panhandle i don't know what
that is um but miami that's where it gets
really weird oh really what happens there
uh i i think that's where it it's more um but
miami's miami is a modern city right yeah so
you can i i think i also would love miami in
many ways in austin we we have uh uh we have um
we have uh uh our dj and fund manager lives in
miami we have an internal djing fund run by uh
a kid [ __ ] brilliant kid he's still how old is
he what's a kid how old is he i think he's i think
he's 22. damn that is what he's meant but he's
been in d5 for you know like three years now and
he's been in crypto for like five years and he's
an absolute [ __ ] stud anyway he lives in miami
no i love that i think the whole what like this
this is why i don't care about i i don't care
about uh you know aids or pedigree or any of this
[ __ ] i don't give a [ __ ] we we turned down
uh you know harvard zuma kamladi grads all
the time i don't give a [ __ ] about any
[ __ ] i just care about uh hustle and industry
knowledge and uh ability to get cool [ __ ] done
uh so i i would hire a 62 year old or 22 year old
or a 17 year old or i don't give a [ __ ] but yeah
we so we have a kid a kid that manages our
internal dji fund and he does an absolutely
[ __ ] fantastic job he's just a complete stud
where did you find him where did you find him
he cold-called us as a recall i really [
__ ] said in my twitter dms there you go
and we we on the regular interview hundreds of
people to find one guy or girl and and he he
he uh so he came on as an intern and he's just a
[ __ ] animal so we hired him and now he manages
money and he's in fact he managed money before
he even graduated university so he still had
some classes left it was his last semester and
so he was sitting in [ __ ] class managing money
well always uh you know ignoring the professor
probably and he is just absolute absolute stunt
yeah i think the entire world is changing
something that i always say is that
um university eventually will become redundant for
most subjects um and for some reason that upsets a
lot of people but but it is what it is and i think
that um you know he he messaged you he messaged
you on twitter twitter is where where it's at when
it comes to networking um and i love it a lot of
people get offended when i say that university
is something of the past for most degrees i mean
i regret my degree i did a journalism degree um
worked as a journalist didn't like it now i do
more info informal journalism i guess you could
call this girl i think journalism is [ __ ] cool
depends how you do it in another lifetime i could
totally be in it like an investigative journalist
i think journalism is [ __ ] awesome yeah when
you do it for yourself it is of course it is i
love look like i i the reason why i did the show
today with you is because i didn't understand
what's going on in china i want to understand
what's going on in china i speak to somebody on
the ground like that's that's journalism right
so i love that but not when you um like worked
for work for a big organization exactly that's
what i'm saying that's two different things
actually having a job in journalism sounds
honestly terrible but the actual work of
being an investigative journalism sounds just
[ __ ] awesome yeah i have a story for you so
i used to work for um do you know cgtn you must
know them china's global tv mostly i used to work
hard yes i used to work for them um a television
global division okay yes yeah yeah so i worked
basically directly for the for them um and i
was based out in paris um and i was sort of
providing the european perspective as to what's
going on anyway there was a huawei 5g conference
um and i was working there and i had to i may
not be able to comment on this you know you don't
have to comment you honestly oh i'm like i may
just listen that's it yeah yeah yeah little film
okay so i was um so i was at the conference it
was a huawei 5g conference and um i was basically
covering putting together a news package multiple
different types of um creative pieces for cgtn
and um i was under strict instructions about
certain things that i couldn't do so i uh i
ask a lot of questions because i just want to
understand um i might ask the same question
several times i just really want to understand
something um so for me and i'm very direct in
the way that i speak so for me i just wanted
to know from this guy that i was interviewing
so what are your comments about america
for example blacklisting huawei and you
know you're potentially doing the same thing
i wasn't allowed to ask that i wasn't allowed
and because i wasn't based in china i was based in
europe it was really hard to wrap my head around
the fact that i'm producing a new story and i'm
not allowed to ask a really good simple obvious
question so you know you're you're talking about
5g you're talking about huawei today there are
concerns that europe might follow i follow america
how do you feel about that i wasn't allowed
but i'm not convinced that's so different this is
not a defense of cgtn by the way it's a critique
of american media is what it is so i want to
be clear on that point i'm not convinced that's
so different than fox news or sinclair which
is a network of news stations in the united
states i'm not convinced it's totally
different from that well i mean i don't
think that i would be in trouble if i ask
those questions in america and when i was told
you know basically you would you could lose your
job i think i can't comment on that they don't
know but what i do know is that i was told to make
a fluff piece not a serious news piece that's what
i was yeah i i'm sure i'm sure i'm not convinced
that from fox news or sinclair is my boy maybe i
i don't know but i i don't know but i was i was
it was interesting and then at the conference as
well when i interviewed the guy um there was
just so much security watching the interview
yeah yeah no government official anything
like that just somebody at huawei um
and yeah all eyes all eyes while the interview was
happening and i was like wow this is it's strange
it was a really weird experience um but since
you um at cena global capital um since you guys
specialize in um finding those hidden gems i think
that's what i read on your website you called them
hidden we we also invest in super high profile
companies and projects like uh you know ftp and
solana in serum but um i i kind of view um the
real job or the real talent of a vc is is um
is finding uh talent and opportunities in
unexpected places uh so for sure we we do both but
maybe i guess i like underdogs so my my heart
is maybe in the gems maybe you could you could
think of it that way that way maybe can you
tell us i like underdogs and outsiders like
who oh well i mean just like a general comment
you know okay so you're obviously interested
no no you go for it go for it well i mean i
don't know it's it's more fun to find some random
[ __ ] genius in [ __ ] lisbon than it is to find
a third generation stanford grad backed by sequoia
isn't it like more fun i think it's more fun
you know i mean look what we do both you know
but my heart my heart i'm more passionate
about finding the people that fail pattern
matching but they're [ __ ] awesome you know
pattern species have their pattern matching
right and so they look for uh you know
a small certainly silicon valley dc's
would rather see a stanford drop out than
than the the best student in the last 10
years at purdue you know so i'd rather look
for people that fail traditional pattern
matching tests but they're [ __ ] awesome and
i'd rather invest in them and then i have 1.4
billion people i can introduce them to and
we can try to make some things happen so i
you know i i we look we do both but i
might i know where my heart is you know
no i get that i get one it's far
more rewarding um but just finally
i'm interested to hear um why
you're excited about solana
so uh i think that um it's about design space and
so um we also are enormously bullish on ethereum
ethereum is [ __ ] amazing colic is a goddamn
legend so ethereum right now is kind of like
the default in many ways for d5 right it's your
everyday car and it's a [ __ ] great car would
be super comfortable comfortable recommending
this car to anyone so um now if this is your
everyday car i don't know what's a good everyday
car i don't know a [ __ ] volvo i don't know
so if this is your volvo which is a safe car
it's a dependable car it's a good everyday car
um super comfortable recommending it but there's a
limited space of things you can do with a volvo uh
so solana on the other hand is like your weekend
car and it's a goddamn [ __ ] ferrari this is your
performance car so um a performance car opens
up a whole vast design space by which i mean
all sorts of new applications all
sorts of new things that you can do
so solana has a fundamentally um different
uh transaction cost and transaction speed
it's uh you know one or two orders of magnitude uh
faster and cheaper to be using the solana ferrari
versus the ethereum volvo which i also again
[ __ ] love because it's it's a great car
um so especially solana i think will
be super well suited for fintech
decentralized fintech applications uh that have
high performance needs which is why you see
um jump trading i'm not sure how widely known jump
trading is because it's uh elite in the same sense
as goldman sachs but they're not public facing
so many people don't know what trump trading is
but basically for tradfy jump trading is one
of the very most elite trading firms in the
world on the caliber as jane street if you
probably haven't heard of jane street either
because again not public facing they just trade
their own capital and they have no need for people
to know who they are but that's where sam bankman
freed came from he went from mit to jane street
to to to alameda and ftx so anyway the point
is that that's why jump trading which is now
um spending an enormous amount of time on five
they have uh they have two partners that manage
the firm and one of the two partners
is personally managing it managing d5
efforts and he and they have uh you know at
this point dozens of people focused on d5
uh and they are very focused on solana uh and
serum because of its unique suitability for d5
uh for high performance d5 in fact they're
launching a uh a new project soon it's called pith
which is being spun out of uh of jump
trading it's an in it's a uh it's an oracle
related project but anyway the point
is that um uh solana opens up and serum
opens up a whole new design space uh
because that kind of transaction speed
and cost is is so fundamentally important um
in in finance so i think we will also have
other interesting applications come out of this
new vast design space that's only the first one
and they may be very unrelated to
d5 in fact i i believe we will see
people experimenting with some of these ideas
that were premature and ultimately disastrous in
2017 a lot of times timing is is is so important
so i believe uh now that we have solana people
will revisit ideas such as decentralized
social networks decentralized you know twitter
things like that and they might have uh a much
higher chance of success versus in 2017 when when
we got these projects we we basically were like
this is ridiculous this is this is a stupid idea
but now they might actually make sense um so uh
basically it's about that design space and it's
about if you have something that's ten thousand
times faster and ten thousand times times cheaper
all of a sudden you can do so many cool things
and i i'm not even i don't think anyone knows
what some of these things will be yet but there's
definitely going to be amazing creativity coming
out of this new design space so we were even
though we we are sitting on an enormous stack
of ethereum and are hugely bullish on ethereum
we're just so excited about solana and serum
yeah i think what we're at a stage now where
you're absolutely right it's all about timing
um i even think politically we've seen um we've
had a lot of hostility um towards our space online
um which kind of creates the need and pushes the
need more for these decentralized applications
web 3 and all of it so no i'm totally with you
i think it's really exciting um i hold some soul
that's why i asked you um so yeah i'm excited i
guess you're gonna make it gmi i hope i make it
i hope i make it i don't know we'll have to see um
but matthew i want to thank you so much for coming
on i almost forgot i promised i would give a shout
out to my friends the lunatics at uh cope which
is a sino project and they have one of the most
intense [ __ ] amazing communities and i love them
so much and so i promised i would give a shout
out to the cope ape army my my lunatic friends
at cope i promised i would do that so thank
you there you go no that's absolutely fine
matthew i want to thank you so much wait hold
on where's your where's your where's your coke
where's i don't have any i don't
have any well you have to have a copy
i don't know what that is what's a
copy so cope is a solana based project
it's a dyno portfolio company and so we really
love the community and we thought a fun thing
would be for for the big cup holders for every
one of them we adopted an actual [ __ ] ape
you adopted an ape yeah we adopted
like 10 12 apes they're in rwanda
so you should get a name that's my point
we adopted like really they're in rwanda
being taken care of by an environmental
conservation group so it's just something
for you to think about i will think about it thank
you for sharing that's actually really interesting
um i'll have to find out more information on that
but wait matthew before we go where can people
where can people find you where can people follow
you and see what you're up to so the easiest
ways to find me are on either uh twitter or
wechat um so for my my twitter is maddie sino
and the sino global twitter i guess it's sino
global cap cap that's the easiest way to find me
there you go i thank you so much it's been really
good honestly i've been wanting to learn more and
understand more about what's going on um where you
are so yeah i really appreciate um you speaking
on it and i enjoyed how you spoke around the
subject i thought that was entertaining so
i enjoyed it as well thanks absolutely
so everyone thank you for tuning in
and we will see you next week bye bye okay